good to see you again nice to see you
but I'm so excited as is everyone for
the return of Will and Grace what's it
feel like for you it's it's very family
reunion yeah you know I think I've been
surprised actually at how positive it
all is is that we live in a cynical
world you know and when a show comes
back you think the first response would
be oh I guess I guess they need the
money or we test it and there hadn't
been any of that there's been a lot of
joy I think a lot of it is because when
the show finished there was a certain
cynicism we had three guest stars a week
on that show for the last five seasons
and and I think and we knew it was time
to go whenever but if you love something
set it free and if it comes back you
know and I think that's what's happened
is that people have discovered it in the
reruns a lot of young people have
discovered it the way the way we used to
watch Brady Bunch they watched Will &
Grace and so suddenly there's this
multi-generational hello that is coming
our way that we just did not expect was
it hard to get to this point I mean
sometimes you think about rebooting
something and getting it going again or
was it really just like we didn't miss a
step this one happened in such a strange
way because we all you know Deborah's
had a couple of series I've had a couple
of series we we all are living our lives
we got a call last summer to do this to
put the show together again for 10
minutes on behalf of Hillary Clinton
what she didn't ask over was something
we wanted to do top secrets and the next
thing you know it's all over social
media and NBC starts talking reboot so
it came out of a very organic
off-the-cuff kind of thing it was there
was never any kind of plotting
machination involved better yeah it just
happened and it's not just you guys in
front of the camera there's some people
returning from behind the camera which
is makes it a real family
absolutely the show I mean we are a rare
show Jim Burroughs directed every single
episode of our show from pilots doesn't
happen live which had never happened at
the left point even cheers which he
directed most of he didn't direct all of
so the fact that it was one guy
throughout an a legendary guy that
that our producers and a lot of our
writers are coming back
it's like Max and David who created the
show we're writing all 12 episode no way
yeah amazing our wardrobe designer and
ours are a lot of our backstage people
so it's it is going to be nice to do a
little documentary about behind the
scenes and have it online just saying
that was more the idea I think they've
had one done when we did that first
thing last September and I haven't seen
it yet but it'll be fun
that's so great so we know where
everybody left off right what can you
tell us about what we're going to see
for that 12 episodes well I always loved
the way Mac and David finished the show
which is we went for the future and we
ended up seeing willing Grace's kids
that never happened so we take we're
probably going to just lose that part
and just rewind a little bit
but because the fun of the show is going
to be just seeing those four characters
in 2017 yeah so we're not going to be so
focused on what happened back then as
much as just dropping them into life
into this crazy news year and see what
they do there's that I mean there is so
much material how do you navigate that
stance well we're going to see I mean
the problem nowadays is that political
humor is instantaneous it is on Colbert
that night it is on Twitter right now
so we have five six week window we can't
be as topical as as other people campus
but we can still be political in our way
and we can fulfill the will and grace
and I think I was reminding something
there today that when we were on the air
it was during the Bush years it raised
9/11 it was the Iraq war and it was the
the AIDS crisis was still a and and yet
we didn't deal with any of that stuff
head-on
we were just who we were and I think
it'll be the same now will we won't deal
directly with what's insane thing Donald
Trump said today but we will
inadvertently be dealing with the the
mood of the country which is you know
more more
conservative now than it was 20 years
ago and you'll be providing some sort of
relief really I hope so from all of that
that's what we do best
your career has been amazing and
continues to be amazing how have you
kept it up here because really I mean
there's a lot of artists who can fall
into the pits of either believing their
own hype or going down the wrong path
and you know how have you managed to
keep it just so classy and so great well
thank you I'm Canadian so we're not
allowed to believe our own hype
so that's scary I actually know her
mother's will spank us yeah don't get
too big for your britches my mom's yeah
I think for me I love I love doing
television series I really do and I love
doing theater which I've done off and on
the last 10 years
so rather than getting into my head
postal and grace that it was time for me
to be a movie star I thought no I just
want to play different characters and I
love having a family that comes with a
with a TV show so I've had I had
perception for three years I have
travelers now and and that's I the
characters are so different so that
that's what's kept it fresh for me and
you're like Benjamin Button you age
backwards I'm rotting and I can't you
think Rick Campanelli it's just like
it's crazy